si quelqu'un vous dit de vous introduire
un truc dans un de vos orifices naturels
en dehors de tout cadre privé récréatif
je veux dire est-ce que vous le faites à
priori non maintenant si cette même
personne vous affirme que ça va régler
un problème ou que c'est bon pour votre
santé est-ce que vous le faites alors
j'en entends qui disent non oui c'est
parce que j'ai loui très très fine donc
j'en entends qui disent non mais il
suffit d'aller faire un petit tour sur
internet pour se rendre compte
que allez aujourd'hui on se refait un
petit passage en revue des conseils
santé à ne surtout pas suivre le
2 la dernière fois on avait parlé des
pires conseil santé on avait trouvé des
trucs 100 % pas du tout efficac voire
carrément dangereux cette fois on refait
un petit tour des charlatans du web et
devinez quoi et ben pareil exactement
pareil mais avant de commencer vous
connaissez maintenant le petit message
du partenaire de cette vidéo un grand
merci à eux et un grand merci à vous
aussi t cette vidéo est sponsorisée par
Odou Odou c'est une plateforme en ligne
H super pratique qui vous permet de
créer et de gérer votre propre site web
très très facilement en vrai c'est un
logiciel qui vous permet de gérer
vraiment plein de trucs genre votre
boutique en ligne vos emailing vos
factures votre signature électronique et
cetera et cetera tout ça regroupé au
même endroit au lieu d'avoir 1000 appli
différentes mais là pour l'exemple je
vous montre comment faire un site web
vous allez voir c'est hyper simple je
choisis l'appli site web et là vous
allez voir première bonne nouvelle c'est
vraiment pas cher vu que c'est gratuit
la première appli est grat ite à vie y
compris l'hébergement du site et le
support en illimité Odou vous offre même
le nom de domaines personnalisé pendant
un an et bien sûr si vous voulez
d'autres applications vous prenez un
abonnement payant ensuite vous fabriquez
votre site juste en faisant des drag and
drop comme ça vous personnalisez comme
vous voulez vous ajoutez du texte vous
changez les couleurs vous changez les
images et cetera et cetera tout est
complètement personnalisable donc vous
avez vu c'est facile c'est rapide et en
plus c'est gratuit en attendant allez
jeter un œil à mon site j'ai mis des
trucs cool dessus vous allez voir alors
et c'est conseil santé à ne surtout pas
suivre allez on y va on commence tout de
suite bon pour ceux qui me suivent au
quotidien vous savez depuis peu une fois
par semaine je fais un bain d'oxygène
pur ah bah non par exemple moi j'étais
pas au courant tiens quelle quelle
mauvaise idée donc là j'ai ma bouteille
qui est derrière moi et tu connais
toutes les précautions à prendre pour
éviter les accidents non parce que
l'oxygène souspression comme ça si ça
gicle un peu fort sur de la poussière ou
un corps gras comme une pommade ou une
crème par exemple ça peut s'enflammer ça
peut causer des incendies ou la
bouteille peut exploser carrément c'est
déjà arrivé pareil c'est dangereux aussi
si la bouteille elle est à côté d'une
source de chaleur comme une cuisinière
un radiateur une cigarette c'est
dangereux aussi si on utilise des spray
genre de la laque du Doo et cetera je
vais respirer ok bon ça c'est plutôt une
bonne idée de respirer par contre c'est
pas un bain d'oxygène du coup hein ça à
la limite c'est un bain d'oxygène bon ça
sert à rien a priori mais au moins c'est
pas dangereux ou alors ça éventuellement
ça c'est un caisson d'oxygénothérapie
hyper barre ça envoie de l'oxygène
souspression à la limite on peut dire
que c'est un bain d'oxygène mais ça par
exemple bah il y a des études
scientifiques qui ont montré que c'était
efficace sur certaines maladies he pas
juste comme ça dans son salon pour le
plaisir et puis ça se fait sous
surveillance médicale aussi donc de
l'oxygène pur pendant 30 minutes à peu
près faut savoir que c'est un très gros
booster pour toutes vos cellules alors
déjà le mot booster bon on en reparlera
une prochaine fois et puis non pas du
tout tes cellules si tes poumons
fonctionnent correctement elles ont
juste besoin de l'oxygène qu'il y a dans
l'air que tu respires c'estàdire 21 %
d'oxygène pas 95 ou 100 %. leur en
apporter plus non seulement ça sert à
rien mais en plus c'est dangereux déjà
parce que ça sèche les muqueuses donc ça
les abîme celle de la bouche celle du
nez celle de la gorge celle des Boies
respiratoires et aussi celle des poumons
mais aussi parce que bah l'oxygène c'est
comme tout on en a besoin mais si on en
a trop c'est pas bon et de l'oxygène pur
et bah c'est trop chez des gens qui ont
certaines maladies ça peut même
provoquer des comas euh c'est un
antistress un antifatigue non euh ça a
énormément de vertus c'est hyper utilisé
dans la médecine d'ailleurs de base oui
mais pour les gens qui respirent pas
bien c'est tout donc l'oxygène si elle
est prescrite par un médecin pour la
bonne raison avec le bon dosage et la
bonne surveillance oui sinon non allez
on passe au suivant vous vous souvenez
des bougies d'oreilles qui ont fait le
bas sur TikTok aïe aïe aïe oui je me
souviens oui aujourd'hui je vais
retester pour voir si ça retire vraiment
toute la cire des oreilles alors déjà
c'est pas de la cire c'est du sérumen
mais ok on n'est pas là pour jouer sur
les mots par contre truc super important
le serérumen il faut surtout pas le
retirer c'est ce qui protège l'intérieur
de nos oreilles et c'est super fragile
là-dedans donc là on part pas très bien
et pour tester on va appeler quelqu'un
qui ne se nettoie jamais les oreilles
Ricardo P Ricardo il se fait afficher
alors qu'en fait c'est lui qui a raison
faut pas se nettoyer l'intérieur des
oreilles faut juste nettoyer ce qui
coule à l'extérieur est-ce que tu es
prêt Ricardo fou leamp franchement reste
pas là c'est un conseil d'AM il est
temps de faire quelque chose que tu ne
fais jamais te nettoyer les oreilles et
pourquoi moi parce qu'à chaque fois que
je te parle tu n'entends pas humaine ça
empêche pas d'entendre hein les bouchons
de serumaine oui par contre mais tu sais
ce qu'on chope à force de se mettre des
trucs dans l'oreille genre des coton
tiges ou des bougies par exemple ceci
dit là dans le cas de Ricardo je pense
qu'on est plus sur une perte d'audition
liée à un traumatisme sonore hein parle
moins fort peut-être donc là on va
l'allumer aïe AE aïe maintenant on va
vérifier et on va ouvrir pour voir B ton
miel Ricardo h mais c'est quoi ça euh
Ricardo mais c'est écurant ben oui dis
donc Ricardo qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
c'est vachement impressionnant quand
même mais attendez qu'est-ce qui se
passerait si on ouvrait une bougie qui a
juste brûlé comme ça dans son coin pas
du tout dans une oreille à skip il y en
a qui's ont déjà ouvert le truc sans le
mettre dans l'oreille et il y avait déjà
de la cire à l'intérieur mais non genre
il y aurait déjà de la cire dans la
bougie bon on a exactement la même chose
bah oui ce que vous voyez là ça vient
pas de l'oreille ça vient de la bougie
donc en plus de servir à rien parce
qu'il y a plusieurs études qui on
montrer que ça marchait pas du tout et
ben c'est dangereux d'abord parce que la
cire de la bougie elle peut couler dans
l'oreille et soit faire des bouchons
soit brûler le conduit auditif ensuite
parce que la bougie elle peut causer
plein d'autres problèmes ça va de
l'eczéma à la perforation du tinon donc
pour nettoyer vos oreilles le petit
doigt sous la douche hop pour nettoyer
l'extérieur voilà très pratique très
pratique et gratuit en plus allez la
suite comment préparer no sauna vaginal
un sauna vaginal un hamam aussi
aujourd'hui on va vous montrer comment
installer dans le hamam vaginal ah
d'accord oui donc effectivement le hamam
vaginal le lanceflamme vaginal
j'espère que vous allez bien non mais je
sais pas apparemment il y en a qui
aiment s'en fumer un peu tous les
orifices donc votre vagin n'est pas un
terrier vous n'alz faire fuir aucun
animal comme ça je je sais pas ok bon
soyons sérieux le sauna vaginal c'est
pas un truc nouveau c'est quelque chose
qui revient assez régulièrement c'est
censé faire plein de trucs magiques
genre réguler les hormones tonifier le
périné nettoyer le vagin augmenter la
fertilité carrément et cetera et cetera
et devinez quoi rien absolument rien de
tout ça n'a été démontré aucun de tous
ces trucs bénéfiques n'a été ni prouvé
ni même constaté le seul truc qui
augmente avec le Sona Amam spa vaginal
là c'est le compte en banque de celles
et ceux qui le vendent et en plus de
servir à rien il peut y avoir des effets
négatifs dans le vagin comme dans la
peau les intestins et cetera il y a ce
qu'on appelle un microbiote c'est-à-dire
tout un tas de germes et de
micro-organismes qui sont chargés de le
protéger et aller coller de la vapeur
là-dedans bah ça risque de tout
déséquilibrer et de provoquer des
infections et des maladies donc vous
faites comme vous le sentez hein si vous
êtes concernerné mais si c'était pour
moi je laisserai tomber immédiatement je
laisserai tomber les douches vaginales
aussi je sais pas si vous avez entendu
parler mais le vagin c'est comme les
oreilles en fait il a une fonction
autonettoyante donc on nettoie à
l'extérieur mais pas l'intérieur on lui
fout la paix à l'intérieur enfin on lui
fout ce qu'on veut mais pas des trucs
pour nettoyer en tout cas c'est valable
pour tous nos autres orifices en fait à
part la bouche là vous pouvez y aller si
si si allez-y s'il vous plaît surtout si
vous êtes prof d'histoire géo oui c'est
à toi que je
parle next voici comment faire la
recette du fameux lavement au café
pardonnez 1 l d'eau avec du café ah oui
donc c'est bien ça d'accord ok alors la
grande caraave blanche là c'est pour
mettre le café chaud et la petite ti
blanche là c'est pour se la mettre dans
le trou ah oui oui oui maintenant pour
faire le lavement en tant que tel voici
mon setup préféré je dis toujours de
mettre un piquet le piquet sert à
justement récolter les petits dégâts si
jamais alors pour les personnes qui
connaissent pas pour les personnes qui
sont pas familières de la pratique là
elle parle de ce chierier dessus he les
petits dégâts en question c'est 1 l
d'eau tiède et de café mélangé avec du
caca voilà pour être clair allongé dans
sa salle de bain donc parce qu'il faut
pas oublier que quand on a le café à
l'intérieur il y a des petites
contractions qui vont se faire et ça se
peut que des fois c'est plus difficile à
retenir alors un petit tips comme ça
pour chez vous si vous avez des spasmes
à ce niveau-là et si vous avez du mal à
vous retenir c'est que ce qu'il y a
là-dedans ça n'a rien à [__] là et
qu'il faut l'évacuer le plus vite
possible je sais pas si vous voyez de
quoi je parle une grosse fasse voilà
mais donc là dans le cas présent je
pense que ce qui est le mieux c'est
quand même de ne pas faire rentrer ce
truc qui n'a rien à [__] là voilà oui
parce que soyons clair le café par la
bouche ok hein pourquoi pas pas trop
mais mais ok mais le café dans le
pourquoi faire en fait pour booster
l'action du foie et le système
enzimatique pour nettoyer le foie et
pour une détoxe de la bille et du sang
ça claque hein avec des mots comme ça
qu'on comprend puis d'autres qu'on
comprend pas trop parce que c'est un peu
plus compliqué c'est ahis c'est pas mal
bullshit total le café ça ne nettoie
rien du tout votre rectum à la limite si
vous en buvez un le matin en fumant une
clope mais rien de plus là encore c'est
une idée qui remonte à 1920 qui refait
surface comme ça régulièrement mais qui
ne repose sur rien du tout évidemment
sintroduire du café dans les intestins
ça risque de les irriter voire de les
brûler s'il est trop chaud d'ailleurs
même sans café les lavements pour
nettoyer le colon c'est une attention je
parle pas d'un lavement prescrit par un
médecin parce qu'il y a un problème de
constipation ou parce que vous allez
avoir une opération sur les intestins je
parle du colon cleansing l'hydrothérapie
du colon encore un truc qui repose sur
une théorie qui n'a absolument rien de
scientifique on s'empoisonne pas avec ce
qu'on a dans les intestins ce qu'on a
dans les intestins c'est ce qu'on mange
à la fin ça devient du caca on l'évacue
ça fait plouf et on en parle plus faire
des lavements réguliers ça sert à rien
et c'est dangereux ça abîme les
muqueuses de l'anus jusqu'au colon en
passant par le rectum et cetera il y a
des risques de perforation intestinale
il y a des risques de D équilibre du
microbiote il y a des risques
d'infection et cetera et cetera bref
c'est comme pour les oreilles c'est
comme pour le vagin laissez vos orifices
tranquille voilà donc des conseils santé
pourris comme ça j'aurais pu vous en
citer plein d'autres je suis sûr que
vous en voyez passer un peu toute la
journée mais au moins vous oui non mais
du coup comment on fait pour reconnaître
ce qu'il faut pas suivre très bonne
question ça voilà ce qu'on va faire je
vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine ici même dans une vidéo dans
laquelle je vais vous donner mes petits
tips pour vous éviter de vous faire
avoir ça vous va ça on parlera du terme
booster par exemple hein mais plein
d'autres trucs aussi voilà DTC c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
donc la semaine prochaine pour la suite
de cette vidéo d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien